what's up guys
so Mother's Day is almost here and
scream junkies the people who run it
made me an offer
they fly my mother out here for Mother's
Day if we watched Human Centipede
together I haven't seen my mom in quite
a while let's do it mom I love you I
love you mom first tell me what are some
of your favorite movies Wizard of Oz
Schindler's List somebody day what's the
grossest movie ever saw Anthony Hopkins
so the Lambs that was horribly growth
the this will make Anthony Hopkins look
like a perfect gentleman so we're gonna
watch a movie today called The Human
Centipede during that title what do you
think it's about spiders are human that
turns into a spider oh nothing to harm
it's no car mom without further ado
let's watch human centipede sure that
looks like the side road as you go up 9w
and with a car park mm-hmm well I hope
that I hope nothing like what's about to
happen happens to you on 9w how would
you describe this guy's looks mom it
looks like he just took an overdose of
something what is that do you see what's
happened what that is it looks like a
chain of animals it looks like a chain
of animals it could not have been more
spot hot now in a movie when two pretty
girls are lost in the woods never a good
sign so they're gonna leave the car and
go for a walk girl no it's not thank you
for the triple a membership by the way
oh it's my pleasure sweetheart don't run
your car without any oil in it I just
got my oil changed but what about that
other car that you ran and ran that one
was leaking but you keep on top of it
you don't let it go does this seem wise
to go to go to this guy's he looks
really opened the door
so did you see what he's doing right
yeah
don't do it what do you think's gonna
happen
I think he's getting ready to do
something major let's be emptied Oh
Chuck you know what's that you curse at
skin parts I want my mom you got your
mom here yes run baby run run run run
run Oh what happened to our arm they
intervene it break oh my god uh-oh
what look what she's doing going back to
safe a friend is this smart would you do
this
maybe pretend for a second this was you
and mrs. Newman
I'm sorry mrs. Newman I'm sorry Barbara
[Laughter]
always pulling on the TV they don't take
the chief napping oh look look he's
making but I'm not watching the farm I'm
watching that gross mom you're missing
the best part
[Music]
so how are they joined together mom
what's he doing mom died this is kind of
gross now mom
let me say I love you and I hope you
never come part of a human centipede oh
[Music]
you know what don't want to deal with
that
honey I want no part of it ah fine
stomach oh good shot
yeah bullseye I think a valuable lesson
can be learned from this movement in
life things may get hard but at least
you're not attached by your mouth to a
Japanese guys at and have your best
friend attached to your written and
directed by Tom six
how would you review this movie I would
say it sucks The Human Centipede mom
you're you're very good sport and I hope
you know that I did this all so I could
see you I hope things weren't so bad you
could do a lot better
what does that be making me throw
won't give you a little something oh
that nice oh how lovely are you gonna do
something nice for your mom you better
she brought you into this world don't be
a jerk so what's the awkward movie or TV
show that you watch with your mom and
dad let us know in the comments section
below tell us how tense and weird it got
and the best answer gets a screen
junkies t-shirt mom
any last words love you too
happy Mother's Day you guys thanks for
watching I'm Howard Nick this is Debra
Rudnick bye-bye
[Music]